Marvel Studios has shrouded its plans for
the Disney+ streaming service in its usual
veil of secrecy, but we've already gotten
a pretty good peek at some of the shows in
development.
Here's everything we know about their plans
so far.
In November 2018, Disney confirmed a number
of the original series in development including
a Loki series starring Tom Hiddleston.
There were still no details about when the
series would be set, or how it was possible
considering Loki's death in Avengers: Infinity
War.
We had so many questions, and then came Avengers:
Endgame with an answer.
When the Avengers go back in time to the events
of 2012's Avengers, they inadvertently give
Loki the opportunity to steal back the Tesseract
and escape from their custody.
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo confirmed
a few weeks after Endgame's release that the
Loki of the past created an alternate timeline
when he escaped.
It hasn't been confirmed that this will be
the version of Loki viewers follow in his
upcoming limited series, but it certainly
seems like the most likely possibility.
While rumors floated around for a while, it
took until April 2019 for the Scarlet Witch
series to be confirmed, and once it was, we
learned it wouldn't be just Scarlet Witch.
During a Disney investors meeting, Kevin Feige
revealed the show would be called WandaVision,
and would feature the return of not only Elizabeth
Olsen as Scarlet Witch, but Paul Bettany as
the android Vision as well.
What we know about WandaVision is both intriguing
and a little confusing.
Vision died in Avengers: Infinity War and,
unlike Scarlet Witch, wasn't revived in Endgame.
Olsen's talk with Variety later in April revealed
more puzzling details about the show: specifically
that at least part of it will apparently have
a retro aesthetic.
She dished that the show's story would be
pulled from, quote, "quite a few other comic
books" and pointed out that, quote, "at the
Disney+ launch chat, they showed a photo of
[Scarlet Witch and Vision] in the '50s."
In May 2019, a rumor circulated suggesting
Scarlet Witch's powers will become more comic-book-accurate
in WandaVision, meaning she'll gain access
to reality-altering abilities.
While there's been no confirmation, this would
go a long way to explain how Vision is apparently
coming back to life.
"I'm really sorry.
What?!"
"You couldn't have done that earlier?"
"I hate you."
In October 2018, Variety reported Anthony
Mackie's Falcon and Sebastian Stan's Bucky,
a.k.a. the Winter Soldier, would be partnering
up for their own limited series on Disney+.
The story claimed it would be the first of
the Disney+ MCU original series to find a
writer, naming Empire producer and writer
Martin Spellman.
The series, titled Falcon and Winter Soldier,
was confirmed in April 2019, along with WandaVision,
when Kevin Feige addressed Disney investors.
Since then we've learned more details about
the show than any of the other confirmed Disney+
MCU series.
The following month Deadline reported Falcon
and Winter Soldier would be six episodes long
and that director Kari Skogland, known for
her work on The Handmaid's Tale, NOS4A2, and
The Walking Dead among others, had been recruited
to direct the entire show.
At the Jus In Bello comic book convention
in Italy, Stan hinted the series would give
Bucky the chance, quote, "to go out there
and have an identity outside of the circumstances
that we've met him through."
Along with naming Skogland as director, Deadline
released other details.
The site reported Emily Van Camp, who played
Sharon Carter in Captain America: The Winter
Soldier and Civil War, is in talks to appear
in the series, as well as Daniel Bruhl who
played Civil War's villain Zemo.
According to Deadline, the series is scheduled
to be released on Disney+ in August 2020.
A little over two weeks before the April 2019
release of Avengers: Endgame, Variety reported
a Hawkeye series starring Jeremy Renner was
in the works for Disney+.
Few details have been released about the Hawkeye
series, but The Hollywood Reporter says the
show will follow Clint Barton as he passes
the torch to archer hero.
The upcoming series will revolve around Barton
training the younger Kate Bishop to take over
the mantle of Hawkeye.
In the comics, Bishop initially takes the
name after Barton dies in the 2004 event Avengers
Disassembled.
Once Barton returns to the land of the living,
as most people who die in Marvel Comics eventually
do, both heroes keep the Hawkeye name.
This has all been covered extensively in the
comics, but as of now, there's no word on
how Kate Bishop enters Clint Barton's life,
or who will be playing her in the series.
In mid-April 2019, a rumor circulated that
Marvel was developing a Hulk/She-Hulk series
with Mark Ruffalo reprising his role as Bruce
Banner/The Hulk.
"I put the brains and the brawn together.
And now look at me.
Best of both worlds."
According to the story, She-Hulk would ultimately
be the focus of the series.
In the comics, She-Hulk is Bruce Banner's
cousin Jennifer Walters.
Banner inadvertently creates She-Hulk after
his cousin is shot.
With no other viable donors available, he's
forced to perform a blood transfusion and
give his own Hulk-infected blood to his cousin.
Since the initial rumor broke, not many details
have surfaced about the series.
However, since the release of Avengers: Endgame,
we now know the Hulk, whose right arm is rendered
permanently damaged after using the Infinity
Stones, probably won't be doing a lot more
superhero stuff.
So, if the rumors about the series are true,
it could be that Hulk will find himself much
in the same position as Hawkeye in his series,
teaching a new hero to fill his shoes.
In February 2019, while promoting Captain
Marvel, Marvel Studios chief Kevin Feige told
Collider the upcoming Disney+ MCU series would
be important to the, quote, "entire post-Endgame
MCU."
Feige also said the series were all conceived
together, and that they would be intertwined
with each other, as well as the studio's movies.
Now that Avengers: Endgame has been released,
along with Spider-Man: Far from Home's final
trailer, we know some of the things that are
different in the MCU since Endgame.
"This is Mr. Beck."
"We could use someone like you on my world."
"Your world?"
"Beck is from Earth, just not ours."
In particular, we now know that the Earth
of the MCU is connected to a vast multiverse
of alternate timelines, which are now apparently
much more connected than they used to be ever
since Thanos' big snap.
Parallel worlds bring up potentially limitless
possibilities.
It's probably why a once-dead Loki will be
able to lead his own series, and it could
also be why the supposedly dead Vision and
the freshly revived Scarlet Witch will be
back together again in WandaVision.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.